who is putin my next guest hosts a new
fox nation show that sets the launch
this monday he is the cause of fox and
friends and the host of one nation the
great brian kilmeade bryant who's putin
well this guy is somebody who had a
bachelor's degree and decided i want to
get into intelligence and he went into
the kgb and he watched as the soviet
union fell apart famously from east
germany and he went amongst the people
of germany and said basically come on
guys get off the wall let's not uh
divide this place up let's get back to
the bean soviet union and and feeling
like you should be in russia and from
that moment according to people that
knew him he
longed for the day to put this thing
back together somehow he ends up deputy
to a mayor the mayor loses an election
he goes to moscow find his way to get
close to power wins over boris yeltsin
yeltsin drinker
got involved in some corruption perhaps
you never know the true story next thing
you know he resigns in comes putin
acting wins an election holds it holds
it for two terms in comes his
hand-picked successor medvedev then he
comes back and he wants to hold that job
for life but i just talked to steve
hadley on on one nation
at nine o'clock and we'll go at eight
o'clock
again after this
and he says this is not the same guy now
steve hadley was national security
advisor for george w bush and he had the
job for about four years a couple of
years before hadley took over and had a
chance to meet him says this isn't the
same guy
quite insular at this moment seems to be
calling his own shot to this moment and
if you think about in the big picture
and get away from the play-by-play and
those horrible images of that tank
running over a civilian vehicle and the
275 civilians estimated to have lost
their lives today you think about it he
is trying to take a country that likes
their leader likes their way of life and
just make it like russia
they don't want to do that so even if
you take the capital are you going to
hold 40 million people hostage with your
inept armed forces as it seems so far i
don't think that can be done we just saw
that
brian you've been studying this guy for
a while what is the change that we see
right now is it his age is it his legacy
that he wants to do does he feel like
he's coming to end what exactly is
making him tick this way because it's
not even strategically the right move
even him being a crazy guy
the word is among people that know
dictators is little by little they
whittle away anybody that gives them the
bad news and he's with a small group and
then factor that in he's so paranoid
about covet 19. he is afraid of getting
it he's isolated himself even further
and what does he see when he sees nato
an attack i don't know why because it's
a defensive alliance never attacked
anyone this is the first time they've
even armed themselves and put themselves
in a position to defend the 30 nations
that we're in right now but he sees this
all as a threat and
he took georgia nothing happened he took
the dumbass region nothing happened he
watches what happened in afghanistan and
he says to himself why don't i just take
ukraine now get the ports get the iron
get the coal get the oil and become
closer to the superpower he grew up
knowing wow
and the ukrainians are crushing this
madman right now and he's spotted i
would say holding him off right now
effectively but i would say for them to
the longer they hold the better it looks
because the more frustrated and the more
demoralized the russian forces look and
the longer they sit there look around
and go why am i doing this i have a
cousin in that town i why am i fighting
here i was forced to sign up i was
drafted sooner or later russians are
people too they're going to look around
and go and excuse me i'm going home
brian kill me thank you hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else